[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend in allen es ist heute kein guter
Tag für diese Welt die ohnehin damit
kämpft dass Millionen Menschen nicht
wissen wie sie genug zu essen bekommen
sollen rund 400 Millionen Menschen sind
auf Lebensmittel aus der Ukraine
angewiesen Weizen Gerste Sonnenblumenöl
gerade für Länder in Afrika und im Nahen
Osten in einer Stunde und 15 Minuten um
23 Uhr unserer Zeit läuft das
getreideabkommen aus dass der Ukraine
Lebensmittel Lieferungen über drei
schwarz mehr helfen ermöglichen soll
Russland teilt heute mit es werde das
Abkommen erstmal stoppen die eigenen
Forderungen sei nicht erfüllt was das
konkret bedeutet nicht zuletzt für die
ärmsten der Welt Oliver Heuchert
seit dem vergangenen Sommer haben in
drei ukrainischen Häfen am Schwarzen
Meer die fragte abgelegt und tonnenweise
Getreide in die Welt verschifft trotz
des Krieges damit ist es jetzt erstmal
vorbei sagt der Kreml Sprecher in einer
Telefonkonferenz
das schwarzmeer-abkommen ist heute aus
der Kraft getreten wie der russische
Präsident bereits sagte endet seine
Laufzeit am 17 Juli
der Grund Moskau behauptet seine
Ausfuhren sein behindert worden
das Schwarze Meer an der ukrainischen
Küste ist seit Beginn des Krieges
termint das Abkommen Boot Frachtschiffen
entmiete also sichere Ruten aus den drei
ukrainischen Städten Odessa johnnymos
und juschne über das Schwarze Meer nach
Istanbul hier wurden alle Schiffe
kontrolliert bevor sie ihre Fracht an
die Zielort weiter transportierten
bisher wurden so knapp 33 Millionen
Tonnen Lebensmittel verschifft
diese Lebensmittel stellt der
UN-Generalsekretär heute fest werden der
Welt fehlen
letztlich ist die Teilnahme an diesen
Abkommen eine freie Entscheidung aber
notleidende Menschen in aller Welt und
in den Entwicklungsländern haben keine
Wahl hunderte Millionen Menschen sind
von Hunger bedroht und die Verbraucher
sind mit einer globalen kostenkrise
konfrontiert sie werden den Preis dafür
zahlen
hier in der Nähe der rumänischen Grenze
Verschiffen Ukraine Getreide über die
Donau das geht auch ohne Abkommen
wir können den Aggressor nicht vertrauen
wir müssen neue Wege finden um unseren
Bauern zu helfen zu exportieren
Nachteil des Transports über die Donau
es dauert viel länger und es kostet viel
mehr als über das Schwarze Meer
zumindest eine aber ist zuversichtlich
dass das getreideabkommen doch noch
fortgesetzt wird der türkische Präsident
Erdogan der das Abkommen noch mit
verhandelt hatte
abgegebenen Erklärung glaube ich dass
mein Freund Putin der Präsident der
Russischen Föderation die Fortsetzung
dieser humanitären Brücke wünscht
in der Ukraine fahren Sie gerade ihre
Ernte ein ob sie das Getreide auch
verkaufen können ist unklar die
Lebensmittel aus der Ukraine sind
wichtig um die Welt zu ernähren
Martin Frick leitet das deutsche Büro
des Welt Ernährungsprogramms der UNO die
Vereinten Nationen hatten das Abkommen
ja mit ausgehandelt und nach der freck
und haben das was glauben sie ist das
letzte Wort von Vladimir Putin in der
Sache
ich hoffe dass es das nicht ist was wir
gerade sehen ist eine der
Hauptschlagadern der globalen
Lebensmittelhandels die bedroht ist
was heißt denn das ganz konkret welche
Folgen spüren sie spürt ihre
Organisation denn bereits jetzt
wir haben gesehen unmittelbar nach dem
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine sind
die Weizenpreise durch die dicke
gegangen dieses Abkommen hat geholfen
dass die Preise sich normalisiert haben
wir sind immer noch auf einem zehnjahres
hoch aber wenn das Abkommen jetzt nicht
verlängert wird erwartet uns eine
Preisentwicklung die für die ärmsten der
Welt große Probleme verursachen wird es
gab heute bereits höhere Weizenpreise
wie wie konkret beeinflusst das denn
ihre Arbeit können Sie uns das ein
bisschen erklären bitte
in doppelter Hinsicht zum einen sind wir
natürlich in einer
interdependentensituation der globale
Handel leidet darunter wenn
randelsrouten unterbrochen werden die
Preise gehen hoch und in vielen Ländern
vor allem in subsara Afrika am Golf am
Horn von Afrika und in den Golfstaaten
sehen wir dass die Preise dann so stark
steigen dass die Menschen sich einfach
auch Grundnahrungsmittel nicht mehr
leisten können wir sehen ja überhaupt
eine sehr große Abhängigkeit in vielen
Ländern vom Weizen aus der Ukraine
libyen hat 43% seines Weizens aus der
Ukraine Ägypten 80 Prozent aus Russland
und der Ukraine ist es für diese Länder
denn nicht möglich diese Abhängigkeit
auch mal ein bisschen zurückzufahren
also wir haben kurzfristig gesehen dass
zu regiert werden kann aber das kostet
natürlich Geld der Blick auf die Karte
zeigt dass natürlich die Ukraine nicht
nur ein günstiger sondern auch ein sehr
nah Anbieter für Weizen für diese Region
ist weitere Schifffahrtsrouten bedeuten
auch bei diesen Energiepreisen höhere
Kosten und am Ende des Tages ist es
weltweit eine Kostenfrage wir haben ja
jetzt bereits mehrfach erlebt wie
wackelig dieses getreideabkommen ist was
denn nicht möglich im vergangenen Jahr
andere Wege zu finden für Exporte aus
der Ukraine
Transport hat wesentlich zugenommen aber
auch das bringt natürlich Probleme mit
sich sie haben es verfolgt in den
östlichen Mitgliedstaaten der
Europäischen Union gab es auch
Ärger mit den dortigen Bauern über die
billigen Importe von ukrainischen
Getreide letztlich ist aber auch der
Landweg kein Ersatz für den Seeweg weil
die Kapazitäten ganz anders sind man
muss sich das vor Augen halten wir
hatten seit dem Bestehen des plexigrain
agreements also der Schweiz mehr abkommt
33 Millionen Tonnen Lebensmittel
exportieren können und wir als
weltanährungsprogramm allein konnten 24
Schiffe durch den Bosporus an den
Weltmarkt bringen wenn es jetzt dabei
bleibt das Moskau tatsächlich aussteigt
wie gefährlich wird es denn dann für die
Schiffe wäre es theoretisch denkbar dass
zum Beispiel die türkische Marine Schutz
gewährt und die Exporte doch weitergehen
könnten
also da muss ich tief in die
völkerrechtliche Kiste greifen aber ich
glaube nicht dass die türkische Marine
das machen würde denn es bestünde ja die
Gefahr des direkten Konflikts mit einer
der kriegsführenden Parteien insofern
müssen Garantien von beiden Parteien
vorliegen damit Schiffe sicher durch den
Schwarzen Meer Korridor an den Weltmarkt
gelangen können Patrick aus aus ihrer
aus UNO Sicht vielleicht auch kann man
sagen Moskau setzt damit Hunger wieder
als Waffe ein
also es ist schwer sich den Eindruck zu
erwähnen die russische Seite hat
Argumente gebracht das auch die andere
Seite des Abkommens düngemittelexporte
gestärkt werden müssen tatsächlich
wissen wir aber auch von russischen
Düngemittel Produzenten dass die
Exportrate fast so hoch ist wie vor den
Krieg erscheint also schwierig
nachvollziehbar warum gerade jetzt das
Abkommen unterbrochen wird Martin Frick
vom Welternährungsprogramm der Vereinten
Nationen vielen Dank für das Gespräch
danke Ihnen und das Interview haben wir
uns technischen Gründen kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet das gäbe einiges
was dringend aufzuarbeiten ist in diesem
russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine es
gibt dafür auch ein Gericht und zwar
seit exakt 25 Jahren damals wurde das
Römische Statut als Grundlage für den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
angenommen der hat mittlerweile
Ermittlungen gestartet zur
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine hat
einen Haftbefehl ausgestellt gegen
Präsident Vladimir Putin und muss
gleichzeitig mit ansehen wie ihm die
Möglichkeiten fehlen etwa den Tatbestand
des Angriffskrieges wirklich konsequent
zu verfolgen
heute wird in New York Jubiläum gefeiert
und gleichzeitig daran erinnert dass
starten wie Russland China aber auch die
USA den Gerichtshof ablehnen Andreas
für Deutschland und für die Frau die
Deutschland heute persönlich in New York
vertritt ist es unmöglich über
Kriegsverbrechen zu reden ohne über
Russland zu reden über die Verbrechen
die eine UN-Kommission in der Ukraine
ermittelt hat als Beispiel Nummer 48 ist
dieser Tag in cherny-hift dokumentiert
der 16 März 22 russland hat ungelenkte
Raketen abgefeuert und eine Straße
getroffen in der mehr als 200 Menschen
nach Brot anstanden mindestens 14
Zivilisten sterben
Beispiel 58 der dritte märz in mutighin
russische Soldaten haben auf ein Auto
geschossen in dem eine vierköpfige
Familie versuchte zu fliehen die Eltern
starben eine Tochter überlebte die
andere wird bis heute vermisst
Beispiel 78 ja hitne in diesen Keller
haben russische Soldaten 365 Zivilisten
gesperrt für 28 Tage 10 ältere Menschen
starben
für 90 für Russland als Staat der den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof nicht
anerkennt niemals bestraft werden kann
für seinen Angriff auf die Ukraine dann
müssen alle Staaten auf unserer Welt in
Angst vor einem größeren Nachbarn leben
ich will nicht in so einer Welt leben
als sich die Vertreter der Welt heute
erheben für die Opfer von
Kriegsverbrechen stehen da auch jene
Länder die den Strafgerichtshof gar
nicht anerkennen deren Präsidenten für
einen Angriff für das Verbrechen der
Aggression nicht belangt werden können
wir sind uns alle einig das Gericht muss
besser werden wir müssen liefern
will gemeinsam mit anderen Ländern die
Hürden senken um Staats- und
Regierungschefs anzuklagen der
Haftbefehl gegen Präsident Putin zum
Beispiel wurde wegen der Entführung
ukrainischer Kinder ausgestellt aber
nicht weil Putin den Krieg entfesselt
hat für mich auch
bäckerstraf
Recht denn niemand darf
im Angriffskrieg führen und dabei
straflos bleiben
Werbung und ihre Verbündeten fordern
auch westliche Staaten auf sich dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof zu
unterwerfen die Ukraine aber vor allem
die USA
das einige besonders mächtige Staaten
vor allem ständige Mitglieder des
Sicherheitsrats den Strafgerichtshof
nicht anerkennen bleibt ein dauerhaftes
Problem
es ist ein langer Weg das Völkerrecht zu
verschärfen und es ist alles andere als
sicher ob er ans Ziel führt nicht mehr
als die ersten Schritte sind gemacht
und dann heute auf der anderen Seite
kaum verhohlene Freude in der Ukraine
über eine Explosion auf der Brücke zur
Krim ein strategisch wichtiges Ziel
allerdings wurde dabei nach russischen
Angaben auch ein Ehepaar getötet und
damit beginnst du jetzt an alle
Nachrichtenüberblick ja und Russland
macht für den Angriff auf die
krim-brücke die Ukraine verantwortlich
der russische Präsident Putin kündigte
Vergeltung an aus Kiew gibt es bisher
keine offizielle Reaktion Videos zeigen
erhebliche Zerstörungen an der Fahrbahn
der Brücke der Autoverkehr wurde
gestoppt bereits im Oktober hatte es
einen schweren Angriff auf die für
russlandstrategisch wichtige Auto und
Eisenbahnbrücke gegeben sie verbindet
die völkerrechtswidrig annektierte Krim
mit dem russischen Festland
die Bundesregierung will die staatlich
geförderte private Altersvorsorge
grundlegend reformieren nun hat eine
Expertengruppe ihre Vorschläge dazu
vorgelegt je nach Risikobereitschaft
soll es künftig möglich sein mehr
Rendite zu erzielen zum Beispiel durch
ein sogenanntes Altersvorsorge Depot bei
dem das Geld in Indexfonds investiert
wird die Angebote sollen zu dem
unbürokratischer werden um Kosten zu
reduzieren bestehende Riester-Verträge
sollen gültig bleiben
der Chef der Kassenärztlichen
Bundesvereinigung Gassen hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen deutlich mehr Operationen
ambulant durchführen zu lassen von den
rund 16 Millionen Ops im Jahr könnten
drei bis vier Millionen ambulant
vorgenommen werden sagte Gassen der Bild
so könne Geld gespart werden und die für
2024 angekündigte Beitragserhöhung
Ausfallen der Vorsitzende der
Krankenhausgesellschaft Gas nannte den
Vorstoß unrealistisch und verwies auf
Monate lange Wartezeiten bei Fachärzten
die sich dadurch noch verlängern würden
die libischen Grenzschützer haben
Dutzende geflüchtete aus der Wüste nahe
der Grenze zu Tunesien gerettet die
Frauen Männer und Kinder waren eigenen
Angaben zu Folge von tunesischen
Sicherheitskräften in der Wüste
ausgesetzt und ohne Wasser und Nahrung
zurückgelassen worden in Tunesien war es
zuletzt zu einem Anstieg rassistisch
motivierter Angriffe gegen Menschen aus
Ländern südlich der Sahara gekommen
zuvor hatte der tunesische Präsident
Sahid illegale Migranten einer
kriminellen Verschwörung beschuldigt
bei der Deutschen Bahn sollen ab heute
externe schlichter den festgefahrenen
Tarifkonflikt lösen das ist heute
losging haben beide Seiten bestätigt
über alle weiteren Details haben sie
Stillschweigen vereinbart wir wissen
nicht mal wo genau sie Tagen nur eins
ist sicher bis Ende August soll es keine
weiteren Streiks geben auch von der
gütertransporttochter der Bahn kommen
Nachrichten die muten ähnlich absurd an
wie viel es was Treue bahnkundinnen und
Kunden regelmäßig im Passagiergeschäft
erleben DB Cargo steckt tief in den
roten Zahlen und prüft deshalb laut
Zeitungsberichten Einschnitte im
Güterverkehr und Stellenabbau das
potenzielle Ergebnis kann man sich
denken noch mehr LKW auf den Straßen
obwohl das Ziel doch ist weniger
Christian hübscher über einen Dilemma
und den möglichen Ausweg
ein Termin wie bestellt für den
Bundesverkehrsminister Volker Wissing
weit in einem Brief Verteilzentrum bei
Berlin die ersten 13 elektro-lkw der
Deutschen Post ein kräftig gefördert von
seinem Haus Wissing glaubt fest an die
Zukunft des Lkw elektrisch mit
Wasserstoff oder Brennstoffzelle LKWs
sind immer noch der hauptverkehrsträger
das wird auch so bleiben viele Güter
können idealerweise auf der Straße
transportiert werden nur sehr schwer auf
der Schiene Bürgerinnen und Bürger
wissen das äh die Päckchen und Pakete
die nach Hause kommen können nicht mit
dem Zug angeliefert werden deswegen hat
sich berechnen lassen dass der LKW
Verkehr in den nächsten Jahren sogar
weiter wachsen wird und zwar um
54%. viel stärker als der Gütertransport
auf der Schiene oder zu Wasser kritiker
sagen er ginge dabei von falschen
Annahmen aus
in der Tat der Schienengüterverkehr kann
ich bis zu jedem Geschäft Vorfahren
nicht bis zu jedem Privathaushalt auf
der letzten Meile brauchen wir die
Feinverteilung mit kleinen elektro-lkw
oder aber auch Fahrradkurieren
lastenfahrrädern da ist vieles denkbar
aber es muss nicht der 40 Tonnen LKW
sein das Leiden am LKW es ist so alt wie
diese Bilder über 30 Jahre die Zahl der
Lkws nimmt ständig zu 1,4 Millionen sind
derzeit in der Bundesrepublik zugelassen
das ist Rekord seitdem sind noch mal
über 2 Millionen LKW dazu gekommen eine
Jahrzehnte lange Bevorzugung der Straße
als Transportweg doch derselbe Volker
Wissing der den LKW pusht setzt im
kommenden Haushalt auch deutlich mehr
Geld für die Schiene durch
die Regierung schwenkt um und gibt zum
ersten Mal überhaupt mehr Geld für die
Schienenwege aus als für
Bundesfernstraßen das Problem bisher der
Schienentransport war immer teurer als
der per LKW und genau das sei der Hebel
fürs Umsteuern sagen Volkswirte wenn wir
Verkehre vermeiden wollen dann müssen
wir das über eine Bepreisung machen CO2
bepreisungen Maut aber nicht dadurch
dass wir Straßen verknappen weil das
schafft dann Staus und das ist letztlich
für das Klima nicht besser wir alle sind
mit schuld weil wir online bestellen uns
an 0 € Versandkosten gewöhnt haben
Lieferketten müssen wieder regionaler
werden und ja auch teurer der Preis um
eine wahre von A nach B zu
transportieren muss steigen nehmen wir
mal den berühmten Joghurtbecher und den
Joghurt Herstellungsprozess der quer
durch Europa organisiert wird das ist
ein Kind der Globalisierung wo der
Transport nichts gekostet hat das ist
unsinnig das ist ökologisch unsinnig
ökonomisch und sich nicht diese
sogenannten elef Anten rennen sie werden
nicht von heute auf morgen von den
Autobahnen verschwinden denn es wird
Zeit brauchen das Verlagern vom LKW auf
die Bahn
feilschen will gelernt sein auch in
jeder großen Verhandlungsrunde gerade
bei denen zwischen Staaten bei den es um
gigantische Summen geht helfen ein paar
Grundregeln aus dem Basar zum Beispiel
wissen wo die Schmerzgrenzen des anderen
liegen und aufpassen was die Konkurrenz
macht die Staaten der EU die aus
Lateinamerika und der Karibik treffen
sich ab heute zu einem mammutgipfel der
eigentlich mit Brasilien Argentinien
Uruguay und Paraguay zum sogenannten
Merkurs so Abkommen führen sollte und
dabei einer der größten Freihandelszonen
der Welt mit mehr als 720 Millionen
Einwohnern das Abkommen steht eigentlich
bereits seit Jahren nachdem es zwei
Jahrzehnte lang verhandelt worden war
sie merken ziemlich viele eigentlichs
denn jetzt steht alles auf der Kippe und
ein lachender Dritter aus China wartet
nur darauf Florian
vielleicht beginnt das Problem schon bei
der Frage des Eingangs das hier ist der
rote Teppich für die VIP in Brüssel also
für die EU-Spitzen und das ist der
Hintereingang auch da ein roter Teppich
aber irgendwie die B-Variante heute nur
für die Gäste dabei geht es doch um
Augenhöhe sagt einer der selbst wie
immer den normalen vip-eingang nutzen
darf ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass
Respekt in der Beziehung Europas zu den
übrigen Ländern der Welt wichtig ist
dass wir da auch etwas zu tun haben im
Hinblick auf die koloniale Vergangenheit
Europas es soll einen Neuanfang werden
heute in Brüssel mit einer ganzen
Weltregion oder wenigstens einem Teil
davon zum Beispiel beim
Freihandelsabkommen zwischen dem Merkur
Brasilien Argentinien Paraguay und
Uruguay und der Europäischen Union
720 Millionen Menschen es wäre eine der
größten Freihandelszonen der Welt und
ein Weg Lateinamerika nicht an China zu
verlieren
das Abkommen aber liegt seit Jahren auf
Eis weil beide Seiten noch Bedenken
haben mit dem neuen brasilianischen
Präsidenten Luna auf Europa auf neuen
Elan
ich möchte mich für ihre Teilnahme heute
bedanken auch ihre Anwesenheit macht
diesen Gipfel historisch
doch ausgerechnet Lula fühlt sich nicht
ernst genommen nicht wertgeschätzt im
Frühjahr nämlich legte die EU im
plötzlich eine Zusatzerklärung zum
Abkommen vor die Brasilien an Zusagen
erinnern soll die Abholzung des
Regenwaldes auch wirklich zu stoppen in
Brasilien kommt es an wie ein Tadel der
alten Kolonialmächte
Luder das vorzulegen und zu sagen
unterschreibt dass du dich wirklich
benimmst das ist respektlos von Seiten
der EU es ist klar dass Luna das nicht
akzeptiert kann Europa heute überzeugen
nicht mit kleinen Geschenken sondern mit
Augenhöhe einem anderen Tonfall mit
einem Durchbruch hatte ohnehin niemand
gerechnet aber dann lässt eine Ansage
des brasilianischen Präsidenten viele in
Brüssel hoffen
ein Abkommen zwischen dem Markus
urstaaten und der EU sollte ausgewogen
sein wir wollen es noch in diesem Jahr
abschließen um neue Möglichkeiten zu
eröffnen noch in diesem Jahr klingt
beinahe unrealistisch doch vielleicht
hat Europa ja auch gelernt und lässt die
Gäste das nächste Mal wirklich auf den
roten Teppich
so wir bleiben noch Moment bei der
Wirtschaft Hannah mit dir in wenigen
Wochen startet das neue Ausbildungsjahr
doch im Handwerk sind noch
immer Stellen unbesetzt und hinzu kommt
das ist sowieso schon einen massiven
Fachkräftemangel in diesem Bereich gibt
Valerie was bedeutet das denn jetzt für
alle die sich zum Beispiel bei eine neue
klimafreundliche Heizung einbauen oder
auch ihr Haus dämmen wollen er
vermutlich nichts Gutes durch den
Fachkräftemangel bleiben schließlich
auch Aufträge liegen Kunden müssen
längere Wartezeiten einplanen auch große
Projekte werden schwieriger die Energie
und die Verkehrswende die
Digitalisierung und die Stärkung des
Pflegesystems großflächiger Wohnungsbau
all das ist nur zu stemmen wenn mehr gut
ausgebildete Leute Nachkommen den Firmen
aber fehlt der Nachwuchs Ende Juni waren
noch
36.000 Lehrstellen offen was etwa jedem
vierten Ausbildungsplatz im Handwerk
entspricht das wirkt sich auf die
Betriebe aus insgesamt fehlen dem
Handwerk 250.000 Fachkräfte und das
zieht sich quer praktisch durch alle
Branchen also die Politik wird sich
etwas einfallen lassen müssen woran
liegt denn eigentlich der
Nachwuchsmangel klar der
Geburtenrückgang spielt eine große Rolle
das ist aber nur ein Teil der Wahrheit
seit Jahren gibt es einen Sockel von
jungen Leuten die durchs Raster fallen
weil sie keinen Schulabschluss haben
oder weil sie auch keine passende Stelle
vor Ort finden
Wirtschaftsforscher fordern daher dass
die Vorbereitung auf eine Lehre schon
viel früher und viel stärker in der
Schule gefördert werden sollte und ein
immer noch wenig genutztes Potenzial
sind Frauen Ausbildungen in Deutschland
ist nämlich immer noch eher eine
jungssache vielen Dank Valerie nach
Frankfurt
die deutsche Wirtschaft dürfte laut
Bundesbank im zweiten Quartal des Jahres
wieder leicht gewachsen sein das zeigt
eine aktuelle Prognose Gründe dafür sein
unter anderem die sinkende Inflation und
steigende Löhne in den beiden Quartalen
davor war das Bruttoinlandsprodukt noch
gesunken bei zwei rückgängern in Folge
sprechen Ökonomen von einer technischen
Rezession
die Reise los der Deutschen ist im
vergangenen Jahr wieder gestiegen das
belegenzahlen des Statistischen
Bundesamtes 2022 haben sie 222 Millionen
Reisen mit mindestens einer Übernachtung
im In- oder im Ausland unternommen das
sind 24 Prozent mehr als im Corona Jahr
2021 aber 15% weniger als vor der
Pandemie 2019
beliebteste Auslandsziele von Reisenden
aus Deutschland waren Italien und
Österreich
am Abschlusstag der para Leichtathletik
WM in Paris hat es weitere Goldmedaillen
für das deutsche Team gegeben bei den
Frauen kam Irmgard Ben zusammen aus
Leverkusen über die 200 Meter als erste
ins Ziel und verteidigte damit ihren
WM-Titel erfolgreich bei den Männern
siegte Weltrekordhalter Johannes Floors
über die 400 Meter fünf Titeln sowie
zwei Silber und fünf Bronze Medaillen
landete Deutschland auf Rang 13 im
Medaillenspiegel
der Beauftragte des US-Präsidenten für
den Klimaschutz John Kerry ist in
picking zu Gesprächen und verbindet
damit zwei der absoluten Brennpunkte
unseres Planeten im Moment china hat
seit heute einen neuen Hitzerekord in
der Gemeinde San Bao im Nordwesten
52,2 Grad
und da wo Carrie herkommt in den USA
fast eine Meteorologin die unerbittliche
Hitze so zusammen die Erde brüllt uns
gerade an und die Menschen sollten
Hinhören das sollte eine dringende
Warnung sein an die Leute dass das hier
einfach nicht normal ist MRT Wissen mit
mir
in Phoenix Arizona über 40 Grad Celsius
seit nunmehr 18 Tagen am schlimmsten ist
es für die die im Freien leben sie
trinken Tücher in Wasser werden im kühl
Nebel einer rollenden Klinik von Ärzten
beraten Kevin hender Schott hat in
seinen 12 Jahren auf der Straße so eine
Hitze noch nie erlebt
ich bin auf dem heißen Asphalt
eingeschlafen und hatte dann
Verbrennungen dritten Grades an meiner
linken Seite da merkst du was los ist
Augenöffner in den Nachrichten jeden Tag
schon seit Wochen
dreistelligen Fahrenheit Temperaturen
bis zu fast 45 Grad Celsius das müsste
eigentlich auch leugnen und das
Klimawandels überzeugen es brennt nicht
nur in Amerika wie hier in Kalifornien
sondern rund um den Globus in Spanien
und den Kroatien
fast täglich neue Hitzerekorde gibt es
auch in China also ist auf einmal der
us-klima Beauftragte John Kerry hier
wieder willkommen im Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel sogar der US-Geheimdienst
CIA warnt angesichts der Ereignisse mit
unmissverständlichen Worten
Keime change der Klimawandel verschärft
dramatisch fast jeder andere globale
Bedrohung in den Feldern
energiegesundheit Nahrung die Gefahren
des Klimawandels sind kein Problem der
Zukunft sondern ein Problem jetzt
das Extremwetter fordert Todesopfer bei
Überschwemmungen hier in Pennsylvania
sterben am Sonntag fünf Menschen und im
Südwesten gibt es neue hitzewarnungen
für rund 100 Millionen Amerikaner
ein Wahnsinn wie es bei uns mit den
Temperaturen weitergeht gleiche Wetter
von uns danke für Ihr Interesse soweit
ja und gegen Mitternacht gibt es unser
heute journal Update mit Gundula gauser
und wir zwei sagen im Namen des gesamten
Teams tschüss und wünschen Ihnen einen
angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend in dieser Woche begleitet
uns eine Strömung aus westlichen
Richtungen und das bedeutet immer wieder
ziehen Tiefs über Großbritannien weiter
ostwärts sie streifen uns an den Küsten
von Nord- und Ostsee über die zentralen
Mittelmeer aber liegt ein hoch da
brutzelt die Sonne wirklich vom Himmel
und es wird sehr heiß das bedeutet das
schon morgen die Temperaturen dort
zwischen 35 und 45 Grad liegen diese
Hitze aber kommt nicht wirklich weiter
nach Norden voran sie wird die ganze
Zeit hier am Mittelmeer konserviert
konserviert wird bei uns erstmal die
Kälte an den Nachttemperaturen sehen wir
dass es auch mal jetzt im Juli sehr kühl
werden kann mit häufig 12 bis 8 Grad
etwas weniger frisches im Norden im
Osten und im Süden und der mildesten
wird die Nacht hier östlich von München
mit 17 Grad dort sie noch einige
Regenschauer weg und auch Regenschauer
und Gewitter verlassen uns langsam hier
an der Ostsee Köster und morgen gibt es
dann die letzten Regenschauer am
Vormittag hier an der Ostsee sonst ist
es erstmal sehr sonnig nachmittags
verdichten sich die Wolken dann an der
Nordsee schon wieder dann kommen neue
Regenschauer heran und zum späten
Nachmittag und Abend erwarten uns dann
im Schwarzwald Richtung Bodensee und
Allgäu vielleicht auch mal kräftigere
Gewitter unter den Schauerwolken in
Norddeutschland liegen morgen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei 20 bis 24 Grad
sonst werden 25 bis 30 Grad erreicht und
wechselhaft geht es auch in den nächsten
Tagen weiter ich wünsche Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend